لماذا يلهث الجميع لتبني رالفي
على الرغم من أو ربما بسبب
الوصف الذي نشرته Niagara New
York SPCA، فهو أحمق تمامًا ولا حتى
نصفه، كنت سأكون
صادقًا تمامًا، فهو يبلغ من العمر عامًا يبلغ من العمر 26 رطلاً من
البلدغ الفرنسي ويعاني من مشكلات خطيرة
حاولوا تجربتها  للتعامل مع قائمة التبني الخاصة به بطريقة فكاهية
تقول إن رالفي هو
شيطان ينفث النار لأنه عندما اقترب
كثيرًا من كلب ودود كان
يزمجر ويندفع ويبصق في
رأسي وكنت على الطرف الآخر من
هذا المقود في رأسي.  أنا مثل الرجل تمامًا،
إنه مثل شيطان ينفث النار عندما
يطلب الناس أدلة،
نشر الملجأ مقطع فيديو لرالفي وهو
يحاول عض أحد الموظفين الذي يصل إلى
المزلاج للدخول إلى بيت تربية الكلاب، ما هو
أطرف شيء متشنج رأيته
يفعله  لدغة ضائعة أثناء الاستلقاء في
مكتب المخرج إيمي لويس ماذا تفعل يا
رالف فجأة اندفع ومرر ساق
الموظفين ما سيكون
المنزل المثالي لرالفي الذي يعيش مع أم
التنانين بالطبع المنزل من Game of
Thrones
ولكن Jokes Aside الملجأ سيكون فقط
ضع رالفي في منزل بدون أطفال
دون حيوانات أليفة أخرى،
وقد اجتذب ملفه الشيطاني ما بين 40 إلى 50 مكالمة يوميًا، وهو
يتلقى التشجيع من أصحاب
الأخلاق السيئة الأخرى ولكن المحبوبين كثيرًا من
الفرنسيين، يجب على مالكي رالفي الجدد أن يكونوا
صارمين وأن يتحملوا عدم وجود أي حماقة
لا يفعل ذلك.  حتى لو فكرت في اتخاذ هذه الخطوة
وتبني هذا النتن الصغير،
أعذرني، فهو ليس بالأمر الجيد تمامًا،
عمل جيد يا جني سي إن إن نيويورك